happy thanksgiving hopefully you're on
your second meal this turkey day and
haven't gotten into any arguments over
politics
get ready for lots of fun we're going to
answer your fan mail questions for the
entire hour so let's get started first
question instagram question from ash
mock one two three each person at the
five tables in charge of one thing on
thanksgiving cooking doing the dishes
etc
who is doing what all right so let's who
is the best cook let's start there
i'm a zero in there
you i thought you might be a good cook
no i'm an excellent bartender okay okay
geraldo is the bartender
what are you are you good at anything on
uh thanksgiving uh cleaning okay you do
the dishes being alone so
in real life no one's going to help you
do that i am the remote control czar i
will
what anything that happens around the tv
we're watching football the whole time
right okay five yeah okay good yes
what are you in charge of i can do the
dishes i can set the table i can know
that i
i am not a great coach so i'm in charge
of cooking
i can make a turkey
well he says he's a bartender but his
bartending is the equivalent of like
vodka rocks and that's okay well that's
what's wrong with that that's all right
big rum man on thanksgiving okay
all right i believe that it goes with
the holiday i think you're right geraldo
that's what the pilgrims drank when they
sat down
all right
let's go to the next one instagram
question from
amy
sarah bry
what is
the best time of day to have a
thanksgiving this is a good debate
that's controversial this this divides
people dana well i like the one two
o'clock i grew up that way and you know
how we started you started the show
saying perhaps you're on your second
meal okay if you eat at one or two then
you can actually then have like a turkey
sandwich around seven but if you eat at
four or five it's just like then you're
just so full before dinner you're
nodding your head are you agreeing with
this well it has to be planned out for
the appropriate time for itis naps
so preferably that you got a nap you're
gonna nap you're factoring that into
your it's part of the remote control
czar's duty is to make sure everyone has
a place to fall asleep okay on the couch
you have your meal at 1 12 30 1 o'clock
okay nap watch the game then around five
or six you re-up okay and then you kind
of nap again and then that's when the
adult the older adults come in with the
desserts and stuff aren't they aren't
there two games now one o'clock there's
like 18 now yeah
yeah they're just always be the detroit
lions detroit cowboys and detroit lions
are always playing and there's an extra
game right and detroit always loses
traditionally
uh so are you in early or are you a late
dinner what's your day i'm up four to
six four to six because by the time
everybody gets there you know there's a
lot of logistics involved right yeah you
know big family yeah
i'm one of five and they've got kids and
grandkids now so to herd everybody
around so you're not doing the second
dinner as these two are no no i get
drunk and i fall asleep i watch the
second game i get up i have a turkey
sandwich as long as there's cranberry
sauce okay but it's a great holiday i'm
very very thankful
middle of the afternoon because if you
wait too late in the day like four or
five people have been drinking all day
and there will be fisticuffs before the
meal
so you need to have it middle of the day
before people are just totally soused
okay i think i'm in the four to six zone
i don't want to be offensive to anybody
but listen if if you want to serve food
that early i'm not going to turn it down
next question instagram from broderick
chic
finish this phrase
it's not thanksgiving until geraldo i
taste the cranberry sauce that is now
and not not special cranberry sauce
because i had some gourmet cooks in my
family over the many years and my
various
uh wives
but the best cranberry sauce is the one
that comes in the can uh wow what do
they call it the one from the cranberry
and a can ocean
ocean spray
breaker phenomenal when you taste that
and it just kind of melts it's gotta
it's it conjures up all the memories do
you wait until thanksgiving day i do i
do not have conversations any day but
that day all right wow cranberry sauce
in a can i did not see that coming here
all day
you can slice it easily and it eats
better on a sandwich that night or the
following day although cranberry sauce
is the easiest thing to make on the
planet it's like sugar and cranberries
and that's right so what is it
finish that phrase uh until somebody
passes out okay
okay you're good i like that
and for all those bartending that could
be earlier in the day
it's not thanksgiving until well you
have the macy's thanksgiving day parade
and that's fine and all but
now in the last oh gosh 10 years or so
there's the national dog show
that comes on right after the parade
it's hosted by john o'hurley and that's
when i know dinner's coming soon that
guy's got a great voice what about you
uh it's not thanksgiving until a
relative makes a stupid comment that
everyone goes for real we were just
trying to
it's just it's it's not thanksgiving
until you you see it's clicking in their
head they're looking around you're going
across going please don't let it be on
my side of the family this year and it's
always the same thing
i'm with tyrus the minute my mom brings
up trump then thanksgiving started yeah
it's on but it doesn't have to be
political it can be something
i mean dredging something up from your
past like you know some
boy you might have dated when you were
in college who was highly objectionable
like tyra's hitting the nail on the head
and that's when it gets like you're just
like
i i don't remember the casserole that'll
that'll stop the conversation real quick
and it really that that
is such a buzz wrecker yeah when that
happened
i want everybody to love each other i
want everybody to get along especially
on thanksgiving we should be thankful
can't we all get along you said that
harold who can't we all get along uh
rodney king all right that's right l.a
riots correct glad we talked glad we're
talking about that today
facebook question from sheri you did
your family have a kid's table actually
no you know what we're not going to do
that one this is better any thanksgiving
tradition or dishes that you would like
to see banned for all eternity so this
is interesting one person usually has
one thing if it's a side some people
think cranberry sauce needs to go
do you think anything needs to be banned
cancel culture on thanksgiving gotta go
ham ham substitute you sometimes in
neighborhoods you end up having to make
the rounds and you go to that one house
you're like where we didn't do turkey
this year we made a ham you should be
able to drop a few f-bombs explicitives
call them commies and walk out of the
house
easter maybe even christmas i'll give
you christmas i'll give you a christmas
thanksgivings exclusively for turkeys
what would you cancel brussels sprouts
yeah even if you sex them up with
pencils
nothing no you just no no not even
considering i've tried that i haven't
fallen for that you have and you just
chew on it like a cow eating her because
like over and over
no one looks that good when they're
chewing brussels sprouts mac and cheese
mac and cheese i just why are you so
redundant you know peop a lot of people
make mac and cheese sides and the kids
go for the mac and cheese rather than
the turkey and it's just all calories
and cheesy gookies that's what childhood
is about so now we know who the one who
ruins the
this guy wants to talk about nutritional
facts at thanksgiving literally nothing
on the table is good for you no mac and
cheese but grandma's making cheeses
cranberry sauce in a can cranberry sauce
in a can and no brussels sprouts either
because they are so stringy they're
getting you what are you cancelling uh
fried brussels sprouts you deep fry them
oh that's sweet i mean
it's gonna be better pretty delicious
tastes like crickets than those crickets
we already know who's ruining who's
ruining the meal
yeah about bugs carbs
exactly
um and
ham is always served in most southern
you serve turkey and ham or ch you
always you just offended the south you
always do business
turkey's the main deal
if it comes down to if i come to your
house and you just have a ham you will
be offended all right and here's my
right hand south of the mason dixon line
and this is bill tyrus this is a
virginia thing i hope but like their
family members who always want to make
stuffing with oysters
no don't do that don't necessarily i
mean they're cooked it's cooked in the
stuffing but it's like little weird
surprises that yeah i'm not with them
but you know we don't have to love it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else